es gibt ja das ist jetzt also ihrem auto
sitzt am finger tragen und zu erwähnen
leibt und lebt
ich mache ich weiß nicht was passiert
aber für mich ist einfach bingo dass er
jetzt bin
in dieser geschichte geht es darum wie
schwer es ist einen geliebten menschen
loszulassen und wir uns dieser schmerz
zu potenziellen kunden einer innovativen
branche macht
er hält alles für mich alles nur klassik
finden nur das schlag konnte ich weiß
dass jetzt wirklich freuen wenn ich das
- es ist so schnell kommen wie hendrik
becker sondern hinter sehen sie in den
wochen besingt sie und auch tragisch 90
tagen gestorben
das ist alles
unwahrscheinlich schnell kommen
total ganz körperlich verletzt
wurde geschrieben aber nicht zum doktor
oder mehr ganz so gut
ja ja
auf dem gelände der ems chemie in domat
ems hat sich eine firma angemietet die
aus der asche von toten diamanten macht
der 33-jährige rinaldo willi ist der
kopf hinter der idee angefangen hat
alles in der handelsschule als willis
klasse einen englischen text über die
künstliche herstellung von diamanten
lars
das kann sie tief rede von xy
informationsaktion algerischen schöner
gedanke oder diamanten zu machen was
werd ich mache ich nicht entsorgt zum
klassischen sehenswerte gesteht eine
familie aus st es geht ein
familienerbstück über generationen mit
nicht verstanden
ganz anders willi ist mittlerweile
millionär zumindest auf dem papier denn
sein ganzes geld steckt in seiner firma
darum soll dieses know-how geheim
bleiben
danke in einem komplizierten chemischen
prozess wird aus der asche verstorbener
graphit dieses grafik implantiert
ingenieurin eine form die ähnlich wie
eine barbie puppe aufgebaut ist diese
form wird in eine maschine eingespannt
die so viel druck aufbaut wie wenn eine
60 kilometer hohe wassersäule darauf
drücken würde
unter diesem extremen druck wächst nun
ein rohdiamant
je länger der druck aufrechterhalten
wird desto größer ist am ende der
rohdiamant die kleinsten kosten 4000
franken die größten 20.000 je nach
zusammensetzung des ausgangsstoffes also
der kremation sasha verfärbt sich der
rohdiamant ganz individuell
größe von maine streik untersagt und der
kremation sich amerikaner knieprothese
medikamente wo man kann als bestandteil
bundes enthalten sind und
dementsprechend 260 euro flossen oder
wachstum beeinflussen
mittlerweile hat willis firma ableger in
26 ländern produktion administration und
vertrieb bleiben in domat/ems mitsamt
den dazugehörigen acht arbeitsplätzen
und damit es weltweit eigentlich der
deutschsprachige raum bedient also
fragen und werden koordiniert weltweit
wenn mir jemand zum versenden da
prächtiger dessen wird alles da gemacht
aber jetzt ganz kommunikation homepage
international vertrags auf 60 das jedoch
stark unterstützt die größten umsätze
generiert willis firma in europa der
asiatische markt wird indes immer
wichtiger
hongkong hat sieben millionen einwohner
alles potenzielle kunden für ronaldo
will
denn
willi hat zu einem lokalen
geschäftspartner fiel dank aus dem
hauptquartier mitgebracht und noch mehr
ich habe eine original schweizer flagge
für dich du hast ja eigentlich schon
viele
ich bin überrascht dass du noch mehr
brauchst aber ich habe die rallye
mitgebracht gutes material vielleicht
medien china ein mal ein meter groß die
kannst du problemlos aufhängen
es gibt einen schweizer touch made in
switzerland
damit will willi in asien punkten in
japan hatte bereits einen fuß in der tür
nun möchte via hongkong den sprung auf
chinesische festland schaffen sein
angebot bringe er vor allem in hongkongs
mittelschicht an den mann sagt scott von
in der oberschicht weise er indes
weitgehend auf granit hongkongs taifune
leben einen lebensstil bei dem die
familie kaum eine rolle spielen ihre
kinder wachsen auf ohne dass sie viel
zeit miteinander verbringen würden
es entsteht keine beziehung alles dreht
sich nur ums geld wenn in einer solchen
familie jemand stirbt dann berührt dass
die familie kaum
die wollen den tod noch nicht weiter in
ihrer nähe haben
das erste kind der fonds liegt an einer
lungenkrankheit und lebte genau 350 tage
nach schweren monaten ist das glück
mittlerweile in ihre kleine wohnung
zurückgekehrt
geblieben sind die erinnerungen an ein
leben das viel zu kurz gewesen ist und
zwei diamanten
sie hat eine infektion bekommen dann
auch fieber
von da an ging es abwärts wir dachten
immer dass sie irgendwann nach hause
kommen kann
natürlich wussten wir dass es einen
langen kampf geben würde aber dann starb
sie und ein oder zwei tage später hatten
wir die idee aus ihr diamanten zu machen
meine tochter war eine frühgeburt
sie hat ihr ganzes leben im spital
verbracht sie war keinen einzigen tag zu
hause als sie dann starb wollte ich sie
unbedingt bei uns haben
vertrauen sei alles in seiner branche
sagt willi darum sei klar dass die
diamanten in domat/ems hergestellt
werden müssten
unter seiner aufsicht aus der ganzen
welt schicken ihm seine geschäftspartner
also die asche verstorbener stets
aufgeteilt in zwei pakete die zeitlich
versetzt aufgegeben werden
die welt wie zu gemacht wo zusätzlich
möglich ist ein gewisser länder
romantics andrack deutschland zum
beispiel als asiatische raum wird immer
zwei sendungen ort
hänni annullierte möglichkeit apps musik
oder nur immer das komplizierte sind auf
wirkstoffe also krank warum du geh'n wir
gar nicht oder ätzte zeigen
das könnt ihr mir leben einer vorstellen
hersteller machen
wie sind sie denn umgang mit der
situation sehr schlecht
ich habe mir zusammen gerückt ist
klappt das ist aber eben erwähnten
untersagt alle mitsingen bekannter
kollegen aller seit du weißt nie ob man
hetzt die achse der staff apps bieten
einfach nur toll vortag kathode sonntag
ich bin überall gut ist
seitdem war sie nie ruhig
es ist ruhig sie oder truhe selber mit
dem kochen etwas das das ist nicht so
schlimm oder hätten immer können
beruhigen
aber wenn es noch so herrlich süß und
oder irgendetwas beschäftigten wieder
gut
in letzter zeit ist es sehr viel mühe
sie jetzt nach gäste und nach steckt mit
ihrer show freiwillig bereinigten free
speech oder und jetzt will ich weiß ja
noch nicht fest
hongkong ist eine dynamische und
innovativsten volkswirtschaften der welt
ein platz für visionen wo man schnell
nach oben kommen kann
und genauso schnell wieder runter sind
viel schneller als in der schweiz
doppelt so schnell und man lebt doch
schnell akzeptiert schnell und jeden
fall die koalition anfang als neuheit
anfangen und das wird doch schneller
akzeptiert als großen breiten
dimension
an asiens jährlicher internationaler
bestattungs messe muss willi mit seinem
angebot präsent sein
hier werden die deals von morgen
eingefädelt darum müssen alle ihr bestes
geben
scott von sogar seinen vater den er nach
dem tod zu einem diamanten verarbeiten
ließ mein vater wurde mitten aus dem
leben gerissen
als ich ihn an jenem wochenende ins
spital brachte sagte er
wie lange wird das hier dauern ich habe
am montag termine leider hatte den
momentan nicht mehr erlebt so war er den
kopf immer bei der arbeit
darum wäre es ganz im sinne des vaters
sich über den tod hinaus nützlich zu
machen sagte sohn
ein schönes beispiel für die scharfe
kante auf der die ganze
bestattungsbranche balanciert irgendwo
zwischen markt und moral
der tod ist ein geschäft und
hinterbliebene sind sensible kunden die
gerne zahlen für individuelle rezepte
gegen den schmerz aber allergisch
reagieren auf den eindruck dass es den
bestattern vor allem profit und nicht um
pietät geht das darf wieder menschen
akut und männer unabhängig von ihrer
herkunft die gleichen werte verspürte
lerby respekt dort der diamant das
wieder willi wild sich als eine art
innovativen trauerbegleiter verstanden
wissen nicht als cleveren geschäftsmann
zurück in domat/ems arbeitet wie die
allerdings bereits an einer neuen
geschäftsidee die reise nach asien hat
seine fantasie beflügelt
er möchte künftig nicht nur diamanten in
den fernen osten exportieren sondern
auch schweizer whisky investoren haben
ihm für diese idee 250000 franken zur
verfügung gestellt die ersten fässer
stehen schon bereit
auch hier gehe es ausschließlich um
visionen behaart willi also bis nicht
die normalste sache der welt werde dass
ein unternehmer geld verdienen will
wechsel herrschte mir zu whiskey machen
geld verdienen
des geldes wegen ist richtig aber die
der arbeitskreis hat irgendetwas kann
von dem labour das ist sie dass man
immer nach hochdahl wenige perspektive
darauf zwei branche bau und tourismus
plötzlich alt einander stand by call und
dass man seit obwohl whiskys
traditionell sich und schoss die schulen
zeigen kann
mit innovation mit swissness können wir
das produkt wo eine mitschuld welt wie
vertrieb als schweizer radio
meine frau ist glücklich bin
das ist der lohn geld ist damit ich mir
das leisten kann damit aber weniger tot
ist
wie wäre es mit dem umgang mit dem regen
rademacher sind auf jeden fall was vater
ganztag ich sehe was ich mache das
richtig sie oder haben jetzt den fehler
gemacht vielleicht mir immer noch weiß
auch das richtig oder
und da ist meinte wäre ich mit ihm reden
sagte dagegen das zeichen machen oder
dankt es ihnen jetzt alle im kreis
vielleicht zweimal prekär wird so wurde
heuer erneut gravierende moment kann ich
das ergebnis als zeichen über vermutet
aber viel ich weiß es nicht
man weise etwas alles nicht aber für
franz ist für das hilft ihnen verlust
verarbeiten psychiater des schicksals
zum psychiater du hast das nicht
verarbeiten setzt die brauche ich nicht
mich selbst der hund störe ich sage ich
habe jetzt genauer geht alles sagt sie
uns während opera das ist wirklich für
mich gesehen und was ich denke
und so endet diese geschichte mit der
erkenntnis dass uns unser schmerz zu
potenziellen kunden macht und dass wir
als kunden immer recht haben